they can tell us for crazy and we can
say well you haven't seen anything yet
because there are things you has just
received a worldwide release on Netflix
and those who've been patiently waiting
for the show are in for a real treat
there's a lot to unpack from its ending
and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the show and it's season
one finale as well as what could happen
in season two there will of course be
heavy spoilers so if you don't want to
know anything about the show's 10th
episode and I highly suggest that you
turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to season one of you centers around
yo a stalker who will do anything to get
close to a girl named back throughout
the show Joe pretty much does everything
in his power to get close to her even
going so far as the mirror though she is
close to in order to thin out her circle
and make her an easy picking Becca
learns of his plans in the end but it
doesn't do much for her overall and
eventually he kills her two things look
pretty clear for the character with Joe
working a fake alibi that Bette created
him in order to pass the blame for her
death but things don't end there and his
surprise twist ending we see Joe looking
upon another female in his bookstore
similar to the way that he stood back in
the pilot episode it's revealed that
this woman is in fact Candice whom both
Beth and Joe believed was dead she
clearly has a lot to hash out with her
ex and it's an amazing cliffhanger to
end the season on this is completely
different to the book in which the work
is based upon which does not feature the
character in a recent interview with TV
Line showrunner Sarah Gamble stated that
in the first season they decided to
bring Candice back to switch up the
dynamics
she said we knew things were going to
start flashing back to Candice as the
author does in the book we started by
talking about how people would presume
that he has killed her and be
increasingly convinced that he had done
so the more they know about Joe
throughout the season so we just wanted
to do something more surprising and
realized that she was such a substantial
and interesting character of course this
leaves a lot of open-ended aspects with
the show such as dr. Nikki who was
framed per Bex
in regards to a second season at gamble
stated that part of the fun of
continuing the story is that the loose
ends from Joe's pass are still dangling
and could come back to him at any time
he is very worried about the fact that
peach Salinger's family has hired people
to investigate her alleged suicide and
there is evidence potentially sell at
her house from season 1 if you look at
every act of violence that he doesn't
season one that is potentially something
that could come back and bite him and
dr. nikki is in prison and he is
ardently protesting his innocence it's
too soon to say definitely whether John
Stamos will return in season two but we
have been talking a lot about the
character and we're excited to keep
telling that story well I love about the
show itself is that it perfectly depicts
Joe as a person who is able to
rationalize things from his point of
view the fact that we are treated Hayes
narration means that we are able to see
things from his POV and some could even
say in the beginning that he is likable
to me this highlights the dangers of
social media and perception the fact
that people such as Joe are able to gain
such insights into our lives and even
appear charming almost perfect for us
due to the information that we give so
freely out is very worrying whilst the
execution in the show is sometimes poor
and the ending may have put many off I
actually really appreciated the fact
that they took a risk and didn't give us
the Hollywood ending that many thought
would play out season 1 showcases that
there is good and evil within all of us
and the choices that we make have
everlasting repercussions
Joe could have easily been a good person
due to his intelligence and ability to
be kind however like many serial killers
due to trauma in his past he has decided
to go a darker route it's fascinating to
me and I can't wait to see what happens
in season 2 so what were your thoughts
on you were you surprised by the ending
and what would you like to see in season
2 comment below and let me know and if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and check out my breakdown of the
trailer for us which will be linked at
the end this is a channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]